[Musik]
und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend es liegt seit Tagen
in der Luft dass in die Verhandlungen um
die Freilassung von Geiseln Bewegung
gekommen ist nicht zuletzt weil der
US-Präsident durchblicken ließ man sei
einer Einigung nahe Israels
Regierungschef Netanyahu hat sich vor
einer halben Stunde nur relativ Waage
dazu geäußert Angehörige der Geiseln
haben sich in Tel Aviv vor dem verteidig
Ministerium versammelt in dem zur Stunde
das israelische Kabinett tagt mehr als
200 Menschen darunter viele Kinder sind
seit mehr als 6 Wochen
verschleppt Michael Bewerung in Tel Aviv
was ist aus der Kabinettssitzung bisher
herausgedrungen also die Sitzung läuft
noch immer aber premieranaho hat zu
Beginn indirekt bestätigt dass es auf
jeden Fall einen geiseldeal geben wird
was an Details aus der Sitzung dringt
ist zum Teil
widersprüchlich klar ist dass mindestens
vor allem Kinder und Frauen als Geiseln
freigelassen werden sollen im Austausch
im Verhältnis
1:3 mit palästinensischen Gefangenen
israelischen Gefängnissen es soll eine
Waffenruhe von etwa vier Tagen geben und
dann soll immer pro Tag 10 oder mehr
Gefangene ausgetauscht werden und was
auch herausgedrungen ist aus der Sitzung
dass offenbart egal ob jetzt weitere
Geiseln freigelassen werden der Zugang
zu den noch verbliebenen Geiseln für das
Rote Kreuz gewährleistet werden soll
damit man weiß in welchem Zustand sind
die Geiseln wie geht es Ihnen wie ist
ihr Gesundheitszustand und dieser Deal
soll aber möglicherweise dann als
Blaupause dienen wenn er funktioniert
wenn die Waffenruhe eingehalten wird
dass dann noch weitere Geiseln mit
weiterer Verlängerung der Waffenpause
ausgetauscht werden könen danke Michael
für diese Information direkt aus Tel
Aviv nach Deutschland mit der
Haushaltssperre hat das
Bundesfinanzministerium quasi bei voller
Fahrt die Notbremse gezogen
Finanzzusagen aller Ministerien für die
kommenden Jahre sind bis auf weiteres
auf Eis gelegt sie dürfen also kein Geld
für längerfristige Projekte in die Hand
nehmen alles kommt auf den Prüfstand
etwas anderes als diese Vollbremsung
blieb der Bundesregierung wohl auch gar
nicht übrig aber ist zeigt natürlich wie
dramatisch die Lage ist aus Berlin Diana
Zimmermann ach leuchtete doch nur alles
so gülden in Berlin wie die Goldelse
tatsächlich aber fehlt es akut an Geld
und künftig womöglich auch an Glanz seit
Mitternacht ist der Haushalt gesperrt
seit heute Nachmittag auch die
Milliarden die im
wirtschaftsstabilitätsfond Liegen
richtig so findet die Union also ein
aushalsperer heißt jetzt erstmal keine
neuen Verpflichtungen mehr eingehen
insbesondere keine dauerverpflichtungen
an der Stelle Stelle und alles muss noch
mal zurück alles muss noch mal
gegengzeichnet werden und das
Finanzministerium muss entscheiden gebe
ich jetzt diese Gelder frei oder gebe
ich sie nicht frei nie war Christian
Lindner mächtiger und gleichzeitig so
mittellos
Schuldenbremse das ist die
inflationsbremse und es ist zu erwarten
dass die moderat restriktiv angelegte
Fiskalpolitik nach gewissen
höchstrichterlichen Entscheidungen sogar
noch ein bisschen weniger moderat und
noch ein bisschen restriktiver im
nächsten Jahr sein wird denn der
Haushalt 203 ist verfassungswidrig und
der für 2024 droht es zu werden Grüne
und SPD wollen Notlagen erklären und so
die Schuldenbremse doch wieder umgehen
die Liberalen stellen sich bislang quer
und setzen auf sparen nur wie das wissen
nicht mal die zuständigen
Sachverständigen wirüerschauen noch
nicht im Detail was diese Ausfälle
icherweise alle bedeuten aber das heißt
für nächstes Jahr werden wir nicht mehr
mit einem Zuwachs des bruttoinlandsbrs
vermutlich rechnen können und wir laufen
dann in eine hartnäckige
investitionskrise hinein genau diese mit
ihren Konsequenzen für den Standort
Deutschland gilt es für Robert habbeck
zu verhindern das Ziel kann ja nur sein
dass wenn wir die
Wettbewerbssituation also die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft stärken wollen und die
Wettbewerbssituation bestehen wollen
gegenüber den USA und China wenn wir
nicht Regionen oder Unternehmen und
Arbeitsplätze in den Orkus fallilen
lassen wollen dann müssen wir eine
Lösung finden die dem Projekt das wir
mit den 60 Milliarden aufgesetzt haben
entspricht nicht gespart werden soll an
den Auszahlungen der energiepreisbremse
für dieses Jahr und immer wieder wird
betont die Regierung sei
handlungsfähig sie sehen mich jetzt hier
nicht als einen Menschen ohne Zuversicht
mm doch die doppelte Verneinung macht es
deutlich die Dinge liegen kompliziert
die Ampel mit sich über Kreuz und über
dem Regierungsviertel liegt ein schwerer
Blues das ganze Interview mit Robert
habbck können sie nachher um 23:30 Uhr
bei Markus landz sehen da ist er heute
zu Gast und dann fragen wir noch nach
bei shakuntala beneri in Berlin also es
wirkt ja irgendwie nicht so als habe die
Ampelkoalition einen Plan B in der
Tasche gehabt also zumindestens keinen
auf den sich alle drei einigen können ja
es zumindest heute noch mal sehr
deutlich dass die Ampel nicht damit
gerechnet hat dass sie ihre gesamten
Finanzen noch einmal ganz neu aufstellen
müssen und auch dass sie einer Lösung
dieser Frage in den vergangenen Tagen
nicht viel näher gekommen ist die
Bundesregierung hat ja jetzt erstmal
zwei große Aufgaben vor sich das eine
ist die kurzfristige nämlich den
Haushalt 2023 erstmal vom Eis zu
bekommen das wäre eventuell möglich
indem man noch einmal eine
Haushaltsnotlage erklärt und dann noch
einmal die Schuldenbremse zeitweise
aussetzen würde dafür müsste aber die
FDP über einen sehr großen Schatten
sozusagen springen weil sie sich da
bisher immer
gegen verwehrt hat aber sie würde sich
damit Zeit kaufen weil dann das Problem
für 2023 erst einmal gelöst wäre und man
die zweite Aufgabe angehen könnte
nämlich die grundsätzliche Frage zu
klären wie will die Ampel in der Zukunft
mit den Finanzen umgehen woher will sie
die Mittel für die großen
Herausforderungen holen sollen es mehr
Schulden sein mehr Einnahmen oder soll
gespart werden das wird ein harter Kampf
werden denn der Bestand von Anfang an in
der Ampel da stehen SPD und Grüne gegen
die FDP das wird auf jeden Fall noch
kommen danke schön für die Einschätzung
nach Berlin und jetzt geht es bei dir
mit weiteren Nachrichten weiter
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
hat der Ukraine weitere deutsche
Militärhilfen im Wert von 1,3 Milliarden
Euro in Aussicht gestellt das werde dem
Land dabei helfen die russische
Aggression zu bekämpfen sagte Pistorius
auf einer Pressekonferenz mit seinem
ukrainischen Kollegen um jerov in kieev
die Flugabwehr sei dabei entscheidend
für die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit in Erinnerung an
die prouropäischen Proteste vor 10
Jahren auf dem maidanplatz legte
Pistorius Blumen an einer Gedenkstätte
nieder in Bayern sind Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft an verschiedenen
Orten gegen mutmaßliche antisemitische
Straftäter vorgegangen der Einsatz
richtete sich insbesondere auch gegen
Verdächtige die in sozialen Medien den
hamass an Angriffe auf Israel gefeiert
und Judenhass verbreitet haben sollen
bei insgesamt 17 Beschuldigten habe es
Durchsuchungen und Vernehmungen gegeben
so die Ermittler es sein Beweismittel
wie Mobiltelefone und Laptops
beschlagnahmt
worden Innenministerin fäer hat zum
Auftag der Deutschen Islamkonferenz von
den muslimischen Verbänden mehr
Engagement gegen Antisemitismus
gefordert der Staat müsse darauf
vertrauen können dass etwa bei
Freitagspredigt in den Moscheen keine
extremistischen Botschaften verbreitet
werden gleichzeitig warnte fer auf der
Fachtagung jedoch auch vor
muslimfeindlichkeit und kündigte
staatliche Maßnahmen an die
Islamkonferenz ist das zentrale
Dialogforum zwischen Staat und Muslimen
in
Deutschland am zweiten Tag der
digitalkonferenz der Bundesregierung hat
Minister Wissing vor einer zu strengen
Regulierung künstlicher Intelligenz
gewarnt man brauche Regeln die die Platz
für Innovation ließen neben Wissing
waren auch Wirtschaftsminister habbeck
und Bundeskanzler Scholz auf dem
digitalgipfel zu Gast Scholz warart
dabei unter anderem für eine digitalere
Verwaltung und den Abbau von
Bürokratie und noch kurz die
Wetteraussichten morgen fällt am
Alpenrand anfangs etwas Regen oder
Schnee sonst zeigt sich nach
Nebelauflösung auf die Sonne abends
regnet es an der Nordseeküste 1 bis plus
6° der Donnerstag wird im Norden mild
nass und stürmisch in der Mitte und im
Süden freundlich ab Freitag ist es
überall wechselhaft und teils stürmisch
bei höchstens 1 bis
9° das war's auch schon von uns weiter
geht's mit der zweiten Halbzeit und um
045 Uhr gibt's dann unser heute schon
ein Update mit Christopher wermann und
uns morgen wieder aufch Wiedersehen
wiedersehen